yeah man
Wednesday and you spilled coffee all
over your white crisp shirt some color
that's fashion bro sometimes a little
some brown spots not brown spots on your
undies but brown spots on your shirt
looks good it's why you wear dark undies
tip from a pro who has [ __ ] stains hey
my friend one time decided he'd fart at
my friend right so we're in high school
friends lie down he goes out runs out of
high school you me last year yeah yeah
and he throw any sports at him problem
is when he farted at him he farted too
hard and a thin line of brown drizzle
poo dust hit my friend on the cheek oh
wow from the cheek to the ear yeah we'd
have to fight it was a disaster couldn't
fight him though cuz my friend was a
[ __ ] doesn't matter friend was the
strongest kind of does not matter you
don't have to it just you have to go do
you have to go you have to represent
your family
embrace duty on your face you it's a
matter of Honor it's like that I'd
rather you spit my face than [ __ ] on my
face well me - I'd rather you because I
yes in other words then should I eat
another one I had to make out with you'd
rather make out with you then tongue
your [ __ ] what's up for debate
little bit no I'm just kidding yeah it
was making us really well here's a
question they can Omega now don't feel
intimate real I was like this mmm
you have okay so you got a tongue my
rump err be calm be calm I'll clean it
bleached for five seconds for ten
seconds no that's left eternity can I
finish
yeah you got a tongue my rump err for
ten seconds get in get involved I get
[ __ ] teeth deep in your ass oh well
you got it you gotta just get it you got
a it needs to be cleaned up now listen
I'll clean it it'll be clean but you
know or you have to make out with a guy
your to make out with me or some guy I
mean in bub slap deep where I'm a swear
I'm into it I'm a guy who's like Titanic
stuff you know there are guys out there
that like you yeah that would love to
yeah sure any girls listen yeah but
let's just talk about that guy you but
you'd have to kiss him for a full minute
what would you rather be does he have a
mustache or beard he's got definitely
some stubble it's got some growth that's
where it's tough I would make him if I
knew it I'd make him grow a thick
mustache
I don't have one right yeah I feel like
an [ __ ] an [ __ ] you know yeah you
gotta kiss them yeah you're probably
right
chin I don't know it definitely never
have you ever had a girl like your
[ __ ] organ no never no that doesn't
appeal to me at all no zero cat not your
thing please don't sue us
good night you think no not my thing
that's really an hygienic time as your
man ever been like hey how about this
buddy no I think it's because we're both
Asian and we have a thing about like
being hygienic I think that usually yeah
Asians excuse me the only scat videos
I've ever seen or Asians well that's a
different Asian which is also in German
those are jokes is also interesting
exactly we're very clean when it comes
to you guys don't get down with that
mm-hmm but they've done suck every
except for that
god bless they've done cycle of Studies
on that in cultures that are super
orderly disciplined neat clean that
sometimes causes a push back in a small
subset of the population where they're
like you know what I've had to be so
clean and neat my whole life if we go I
want yeah I want some poo yeah it's the
same as like those girls who their
parents are super strict and then they
get to college and you get a little bit
of freedom next thing you know the
entire football team has run a goddamn
train on it that's exactly first time
ever having freedom that's true that's
what you don't want man yeah yeah but
you're mad so you you would never even
think about it hunt cat no you never
yes ma'am Esther I just kind of puts his
legs up like a toddler Oh No yeah you've
had that done to you I've had a girl
push my legs I met that girl very nice
lady and then I was like how'd it go and
you were like well she baby baby
diapered me as a grown man third base
well that you're such a big guy and she
was a petite woman so I don't know I put
I'd have trouble pushing your leg yeah
yeah worry about catching a case I can't
slam my legs down [ __ ] up her face or
something like that
I dig slaps in the face like a goddamn
[ __ ] that isn't that is a strange
it's a buddy but people have different
fetishes
people love feet some people love feet
my friend thought that is why everyone
has to see your feet my friend would
nary did the hottest
girl ever ever ever and he goes I don't
like her feet but I go what you know
there's a whole wide she could have hoes
and I wouldn't give it you know there's
a whole genre in porn that and people
just love feet like even watch videos
that dudes Jack another I'm sorry girls
jet was I'm sure dudes chin yeah but you
can watch girls Jack and dudes off with
their feet I get this thing just like
here do it yeah it's not my thing just
like there are a lot of men who like and
women who like old people have like lost
lets disgusting women like that right
porn are you in defeat chin I don't
really care about it right like as long
as they're not super busted with corns
and [ __ ] well I'm not like they're gross
than you I care me to out like in a high
arch yeah yeah I like that but it's not
make or break for me no I'm not like
Jesus Christ man your feed I'm out but
if she does haven't we got a problem
she's got big feet though i I've never
gonna deal with that I prefer a petite
or of a smaller your friend in Chicago
who called a woman of the night and she
showed up and had a size 14 hug on yep
and hands long hands and he said I think
I think I messed around with a guy last
night has to be good and I was like why
and they were like cuz he had a dick
today also because there's only one man
who wears eggs and they only make 14 for
one male on this earth and that's Tom
Brady so unless you're Tom Brady he
rocks out size 14 I'm sure yeah he's a
big dude are you a feat or anything
caddy no but I knew a girl at USC who
used to take photos of her feet and send
it to guys to pay tuition mm-hmm she was
had some pretty ass feet then I think so
what ethnicity black girl well they're
they're they're girls it's their
underwear they'll they'll wear their
under all all day and then put them in
the mail and send them to what what
culture is that before I fend everyone
on this podcast what culture is that in
Asia where you can go to a vending
machine and buy dirty on Japan probably
Japan most likely Japan J's in Japan
right now yeah J pick me up some shitty
undies yeah you should go the vending
machine like it's a diet coke yeah and
they're just all around the town yeah
you know that those old stories about
men who would break into your house and
sniff all your underwear nope I don't
well did they do and they you know a guy
a woman would be riding a bike and then
they catch the guy outside the
convenience store and sniffing her seat
I'm only done that like 10 times do you
get to be a real perv yeah but there are
but people are have weird perversions
but they say it starts when you were a
kid like there's something going on like
something influenced you like I always
talk about this while I'm into ass is so
bad because I found well I think my
brother had his of Mercedes called him
it was a rap female rapper she was bent
against the car like this yeah since I
was then I would [ __ ] off to that thing I
was mighty but my question is was that
already in you cuz I mean no I was like
good God you can bring that up chin
Mercedes rap out but male speed the male
speaking jean shorts on bent over a car
and this ass will blow your mother the
male species of a lot of animals they've
done some studies where they like round
smooth surfaces so you know you're drawn
to don't go to images Bryce see it from
here and already I went [ __ ] 6 to 12
now her face now her face is sheet all
the [ __ ] all the [ __ ] did she
people hope the she interface all the
crawl dads in New Orleans maybe as my
mother said some people have weight in
their face and you know what now I'm
looking at not that great but when
you're a young kid and she's part of no
limit and you want a jack off to Silkk
the Shocker yeah while she's doing her
thing against this old-school [ __ ]
300sl Mercedes yeah there's something
about her face now does she look like
Cedric the Entertainer maybe from here
there's something about her eyes I like
I like her eyes I like the way she's
kind of like confident and she's gonna
you know what she's my heart troubles go
away I'm having a hard time believing
that's her on the car now no no I'm
older I'm like me I don't know yeah you
mean so did they fade photoshopped or
Faison yeah I look at her face and you
know I think can't trust her interesting
yeah well I'm not into women it doesn't
turn me on to so that's a nice
loking a cigar that that's not exactly
that's the 90s was Silkk the Shocker bro
but if I was there and a woman's like a
Shia you know that's not smoking circle
never seen a sexy girl to smoke a cigar
doesn't get to me doesn't do much for me
really doesn't how's the video that was
the album cover that did it when did
that come out chin wonder eyes up when
was I have [ __ ] worked on he's gonna
reach down my pants and scratch my inner
thigh right now
yeah yeah right on the podcast there we
go okay when did that come out you guys
have anything you have anything like
that Kat anything turned on your kid
chin chin for you was it uh Ricky Martin
or some [ __ ] hold on nineteen ninety
nine ninety nine not that young I was
not that young one that came out that
said 1999 yeah well it's not that okay
yeah no I was a full-grown adult when
that came out I apologize to everybody
it's alright you know we used to who
couldn't get enough she wanted sixteen
remember Andrei Arlovski when he used to
be super hairy never heard of him
yeah bring up Andrei Arlovski when he
was super hairy you got a sense of what
he looked like and there was a girl I
knew who thought that that nothing
sexier than that fine nothing sexier and
I said why do you like such hairy men
she said when I was younger I had a
teacher nice way her hair he shaved is
he had hair on his back and everything
look at him go when I found him he had
here on his shoulders yep yep that's a
[ __ ] look at the body on him though
what an athlete but when he was when he
was uh you know she said he would like
to lean over you he had a teacher I had
these insanely hairy wrists and ever
since then she likes a man covered she's
in here Harvard in hair they go to
Russia girl yeah he's a macho dude no
staying with him for a long time yeah
anyways um yeah it's very strange you
know I feel like tears not that in these
days most guys are trimming it tight I
agree I don't see a lot of hairy girls
either yeah well our guys shave even
there can you grow a big beard yeah be
like a big bit like sure thick
No yeah I've never seen yet I could if I
wanted really yeah I can't really no you
can't not like a real thing you know I'm
not here didn't grow a beard easily I'd
like to be built like Andre thank you
everyone I wouldn't have been a fighter
I would have just walked around and been
big oh there is does that the other dude
know that pockets are different dude
that's uh he was at Herman yeah it
doesn't look bad
something Herman you know he doesn't
look terrible he's just such a hairy
[ __ ] up to her here look at all Dave's
agony look at Dave pee-wee Herman look
at him he's got a great he's got a great
bill he's a heavyweight he was trouble
doing for something look at the hair all
over his body that's really hurt
that's wild but it actually looks pretty
cool on him he's a freak jeez I don't
remember him is your man
Harry Kent nope that's why I like Asian
guys Syria is there an Harry agent dude
ah not really they're kind of a dime
like kind of rare actually now it's kind
of like an asian girl having a crazy ass
and yes it's just like that chain Google
Harry Asians it's not their thing right
now
mm-hmm you don't see a lot of hairy
Hawaiians either no like Island well
there you go
where's the one he's not a hundred
percent Asian I know he's not his face
looks super Asian though you think he
looks a little like a white Asian yeah
that's a great job possibly some sort of
well looks Japanese sauce got pierced
nipple mmm you will suck you dry too
well that same guy Wow his forums were
hairy yeah he's had you know I'm saying
like nothing pops up
I did see a hairy uh sumo guy the other
day I got on TV you know there's
jumpiness don't think dude how funny was
it last night at the Comedy Store with
Jay Larson
here in front of a bunch of Marines
there's a bunch of Marines there last
night and me and Brian are just make him
laugh [ __ ] and Jay Larson was doing
this a bit where he pretend he was on a
cell phone
it was so [ __ ] funny he's great he's
walking by everyone like you because I
mean he goes man I heard you bombed I
was like I didn't bomb what are you
talking about he goes no that's what I
heard I'm sure yeah her job is good
though and he's
walks away and I'm talking all these
Marines he comes by goes no I shot two
ball count bombing cubes on the phone
he's like yeah no sharp killed no but
yeah Brian he comes makes another walk
back out another fake phone call he goes
yeah yeah yeah Callen scary I think is
anyone hey man all these Marines ah Jay
Larson's a funny [ __ ] super
funny man we've never had him on here
right we have you have a long time long
this time we go funny comic well I
talked to Pauly Shore last night you
saying he wants to come on yeah let's
get him on yeah Paul's got great stories
amazing stories we should definitely
have polygons yeah probably be fun right
yeah Jim tell some of those old school
stories I important have him on that
would be fun pieces comedy history
actually oh yeah oh yeah him mother that
did the legend I'll ask him about the
legend was his mother who was Mitzi
shore the great Mitzi sure who made
something called a Comedy Store never
heard of it and and Mitzi shore he she
would let him cry in the crib and they'd
be like you know you should get him
because now he's learning how to bomb
he's learning I'm teaching him how to
deal with like you know people
she was just grooming on the babies are
not I mean it was too racy she was fine
choking yeah yeah no there's some epic
stories about her in the way she ran
things she was really sexy when she was
younger by the way yeah yes look I look
up young mature sure and she and even
Polly like talks about how she did have
sex with the comics
that's tough man if that's your mom
right is such a badass she did [ __ ] on
her own die the way she died no she was
great Brian but see if imagine you've
been raised in that atmosphere you're
gonna be a little [ __ ] up yeah you
know I'm saying that's gonna be tough
well he on MADtv he told a story a
monologue about his his stepfather and
it was so funny but tragic at the same
time and it was so good because it was
true it was just tell the story yeah
he'd be about here right oh yeah dude he
grew up he grew up in a place where
people like Jim Carrey and and Robin
Williams and Richard Pryor and the
greatest legends have come where his
baby citizen knows babysitters
babysitters and also starting out
Roseanne Barr
how about that
Sam Kinison Sam Kinison was his
babysitter's you know that no that's
hilarious to me that's amazing yeah that
can't be said you know what I'm saying
like died we should definitely have them
on yeah dude how about last night in the
greenroom there's a Brian was in back
there but there's a box of cookies I
kept a gassing of cookies I was starving
I had one sandwich all goddamn day I'm
talking starving
I see those cookies and always in the
green room back there there's oh it's
weed everywhere they like speed weed
sponsors the show usually in the in the
main room so there's always like mass
amounts of weed pens and edibles and I
think and the cookies are in the middle
of that I'm like god they look so
[ __ ] fresh home-baked like god damn I
want a cookie Chris like do not [ __ ]
eat those Rogen's like I guarantee you
those have weed in them
like dude those things look fresh
[ __ ] bit in my mouth those money's so
good my mouth was watering now what dude
we sure to pizza back here and Chris
like now we can't we'll be off stage by
then I like to let's eat these [ __ ]
cookies like dude what kind of [ __ ]
freak brings fresh delivered truck jeez
my buddy to the Loretto all comics that
don't have we did so I didn't touch it
yeah but I think Rogen put Rogen post a
picture go to Rogen drone goes the
infamous whatever chocolate chip cookies
they're there dude that's my boy jor-el
he made them his wife and he made them
now listen a churro is the black guy in
the front row of the first show with his
girl Jews I think she's Asian
sorry geralt or not anyway they were
sitting the front ropes rolling say
about it there and broke he [ __ ]
babies his wife makes him they're the
best cookies I've ever had
I'm Annie and I'm gonna have them sent
to you for Christmas - please do Asian
they have a list of they send cookies to
people the said of me for having a son
years old man you got to try the ginger
grew those chocolate chip Eugene they're
my favorite oh you're [ __ ] you know
what I'd you'll lose your dick man but
you know I did I ate the middle of the
cookies Jose I cracked it there's like
this big cracked in half once I found
out they're not wheat cookies and ate
the middles then put it back look at
this he goes dangerous choices there are
cookies in the greenroom and there is
considerable disagreement on whether or
not their pot cookies we're currently
looking to recruit the services of a
risk taker for the sake of
I don't write for no and open it feels
open or eight aadum yeah he was like
dude [ __ ] it I'll try it and I go what
do you think I was so hungry so Chris is
I did have him eat him so he tries them
I'm like would you think he goes there
definitely wheat bread wheat cookies I
go [ __ ] man [ __ ] and then they're just
sitting in the back there I'm so hungry
we got to wait to go on is my third side
of the night and then Brian goes do you
guys try their cookies and one's like no
[ __ ] these cookies Brian really know my
friend bottom they're fine I was like
what - its cookies and we love you mommy
we left some there I know guys to take
him on game you don't piss me off Chris
[ __ ] Billy when it try him he's a
little cuz he said I'll you know I
wasn't think I learned about Chris's
he'll eat all the food yep me too bit
but I know what are you talking about
meanwhile what's with your discipline
you [ __ ] he wouldn't have a bite I go
try a bite he goes no he does look
apparently I think was a slippery slope
because if he tried it then he'd eat all
of them I think he might have a food
thing this doesn't drink doesn't smoke
pot and he said he'll eat all the food
mold me too you know I don't drink
could you know pot you have eaten all
those cookies yes no problem no problem
can you eat a hole yeah you can eat a
whole cake I can't tell cake the other
night I like I was looking I don't want
Domino's something I was gonna have like
a cheap meal ripe and super strict
lately if Intel and I decide to order
pizza and I found I look for ones I have
the highest ratings on Yelp like the
most rating of the highest ratings it
was this place by UCLA that delivers and
they get their pizza dough from New York
because official New York slices well
the [ __ ] I'll take a whole pie man got a
pepperoni for me and my lady and she had
to so there's about 12 slices that come
with this big extra large pie baked
delicious and dude I I don't know what
happens is some sort of problem
I ate eight slices in a row I just and I
got done I don't feel good and my girl
goes loboc she's like you ain't [ __ ]
eight to ten slices of pizza I'm like
that's a lot of beets I don't even
remember doing sodium but goddamn it
looks good I mean I will work out like a
[ __ ] the next day and burn it
off but I don't remember doing them
look at these pizzas though it's a real
problem yeah I just keep going there
anything better than there's not it's
the hands-down the best thing on the
planet when it's good pizza when it's
really good pizza I would go eat pizza
ride quit I'd run away from this podcast
right now I'm hungry go eat pizza and
you'd catch me at a pizza place we're
not there's really no good things around
here oh that's my favorite
Jelena takeaway should we do it yeah we
should right right
my I feel like kiddos at Disneyland so
they won't be home about four or five
I'll get some free time sugar fish - are
you sure - fresh ham pizza dude what'd
he do it to me man I'm high my mouth is
watering Jon and Vinny I can't tell you
how bad I wanted [ __ ] those cookies
last night I'm so relieved
daliyah took your picture I'll have him
sent it to us how happy you and I were
when I was eating them hard god please
have your friends I mean those cookies I
really will good yeah well let's have a
moment just you know that's just so much
that looks really good that looks good
man mmm my legs gone not bad
God do you get the business sucks though
huh yeah but my psoriasis is a horrible
MJ gun yeah that's crazy
thank you Dan gonna feel good about it
huh yeah well thank God we don't have to
hear you break it down again I know
think baby Jesus dude but it was good
anyway my skin's back to normal a
muscular [ __ ] how about me and Charles
Barkley you see the size difference did
you see my comment I said you guys look
like the number 10 that was so funny I
didn't say that Christ means you guys
see this I count humfrye it can't look
that is exactly what we look like is it
on number 10 you guys look like the
number 10 I think if you click on and go
to top com-shuk he's such a fuss it's
different you online
oh is that you're such a good guy have
you met him what a [ __ ] are super
briefly I mean I want to say when I was
fighting ten years ago probably you guys
count on TRT Barkley on doughnuts man
he's a big guy he's you you don't
realize how big those basketball players
are we'll see what he's a coach on the
show but yeah
I find him and he starts talking it's
over he's we got a really funny part but
meanwhile he your laser de Luna he's a
[ __ ] human wall they're not bigger
they look bigger there but they're not
he looks at how hard you flexing their
beak I just have big legs but he flips
Monroe strong legs but he look at how
small my knees are though compared to my
quantity he's a he's a human wall people
forget how big [ __ ] basketball
players are like you read see him on TV
like you see Steve Nash like he's not
that big 6-4 6-4 I never think you see
stuff encourage six for like it's their
fight do not step seven very sick not
well cuz everyone there it's [ __ ]
like the the monsters on space gym
they're huge and these guys look small
dude and then I was at I was in
Hollywood doing something and in the
same building
Carmelo was doing something there too
and he walks by me and I mean they're so
big like what we only look like the same
species
I mean honestly so big and when I see
how big they are like when I had some of
those guys I'm like whoa um if I was
that big I would play something William
II [ __ ] you know what I mean like
Charles Barkley's were the greatest of
all time you know that right
wasn't he great fact I certainly did
when he drafted by the Sixers I mean
everybody calling kids that we shoot
when I go they don't know you have no
idea he'd stop playing when they were
born I was like you're playing talking
to a legend right straight-up legend
yeah yeah you holy so good man yeah so
[ __ ] tough rough so so [ __ ] good
he had to weigh I mean I don't know dude
he's three three forty probably because
he's southpaw
I'll tell six no w6 v but no he's big in
six five for sure he's it was never his
height six six six but just big you know
I thought he's bringing that I love
how's his weight 250 my ass one when he
was playing when he there there you get
him and Jordan there yeah that's crazy
yeah he's one all-time greats oh man I
wonder if they took down on me I want
have curls like them back in the day
you see married no he's got a very
pretty girlfriend
does he yeah look at him look at skinny
he is there no I mean yeah Wow
my friends the girls in high school my
friends they loved him good night if I
was hot in high school yeah back in the
days
look at that hon go back that [ __ ]
dream team picture look at that now give
me they give me that's Stockton let me
see if I can lighten let me see if I can
do it all Stockton Barkley Han start
start with number 11 you know who that
is that's that's yes that's Robinson no
car Malone okay well I can't see from
here this is can you really bad picture
to you see if there's another one there
you go alright so number 11 do you know
who that we start I'm sorry no I thought
you st. the top that's Robins up there
yeah so let's start with number 11s
that's that's that's carmella number 12
John stock the only white guy shut up to
him number six tiny guy number six is if
you're Linda magic I have from the first
round
oh yeah Len Bias no nope Penny Hardaway
Penny Hardaway for any Hardaway number
fours your boy you know who number 14 is
number 14 called the glove and she with
Nike they call him Gary Payton okay do
you know who number 10 is between
Stockton and Karl Malone his sister
might be better at him than basketball
yes yes oh come on
rhymes with belly killer
Reggie Miller okay no number eight horse
side piece - MJ yes
okay no Reggie Miller I know you don't
all right and then between Scottie and
Shaquille O'Neal's names I can't
remember do you know who that is
um [ __ ] Payton and now he went to Duke I
cam Grant Hill that's right Grant Hill
dude the real dark gentleman all the way
in the back who's not standing on Amy
came Olajuwon of Kim Olajuwon and the
guy next to him number nine I can
remember he's a dunk master all over the
Raptors always that is that Vince Vince
Carter yeah oh that might be Mitch rich
out of the night and that's Mitch
Richmond yeah that's right Mitch
Richmond and then you got David Robinson
of the dream team now if you don't if
you don't think if you do not think
[ __ ] Robinson was on all the winds
strong you're crazy I don't know you
think all right what is the battery why
wouldn't you back but I wonder how much
they were doing back then they're still
doing today they don't test me no I
believe that they test you know for some
but I don't know that they were that you
know I mean he was just a such a freak
girl for sure possibly he could also
just be a free there might be that I cuz
because he's just so shred excuse me if
he was lifting ways yeah why wouldn't
you though I don't give a [ __ ] no I
don't get a leather ball dude already
such a damn freak that maybe to put on
that sighs yeah and there's freaks of
freaks but listen if gun to the head
I've had to guess yeah why not
especially back then to prolong your
career too yeah
guns not hurting on you I'm saying no I
would say absolutely yeah he was in the
Navy that's why he's my dad's favorite
player how tall was he to be in the Navy
Yuki I thought six six was the cutoff
well you can't slapping feet can't fly
[ __ ] fighters Jackson rapid seven
foot one inches tall I bet his dick is
like a [ __ ] Einstein VIP [ __ ] looks
like my thumb yeah he's yeah look look I
mean basketball today still great though
it's same thing people do with boxing or
the payday through Golden Age but box
right now amazing your see better that's
ever been basketball [ __ ] to me three
basketballs footballs a little tricky
but bath smells amazing
our boy Charles Barkley has had he's got
you know oh go back go to that where
he's holding the basketball right there
Brendan Schaub might be right where he's
holding the basketball right with his
shirt off Jenna's shirt off Brendan
Schaub you might be right because that's
where he looks like he's before all that
stuff it's really normal they're done
they yes but you know what you know I'm
crazy it's normal for guy in his 30s to
gain 30 pounds of lean muscle gets
shredded that's no
or more yeah at daddy yeah that's it
yeah I don't care do your thing dude
yeah yeah like I said gonna Alonzo
Mourning well though are you [ __ ] me
look at that
he had kidney issues right there kidding
you
kidney issues but had no issues getting
ahold of decade let me just [ __ ] jack
I don't know what in basketball know why
you wouldn't [ __ ] do it if it helps
you sure harm alone was no Punk either
the mailman well you know your body
takes a beating I mean Charles Barkley I
said how's your body holding on because
he plays golf every single day he goes
to fake hips and his knees you know he
got the surgery on his knees when they
didn't know what they were doing so
looks at your goddamn yeah yeah so his
knees he goes my Mondays you know I
don't worry about those you know I'm and
basically he said I'm always in pain but
I can deal with it like I played yeah
it's not affecting his quality of life
but by the way look at LeBron the Bron
that's her body the bronze all natural
Brandon I had nothing I won't piss on
people's parades hold on go back to the
well he's like a team in that on the
left is a team he's a team we all we all
he's a freak so I believe that that is
the biggest freak now did he lose a ton
of weight
went to Miami is switching over and got
a program and put on some weight yes
yeah don't be isn't it easy for some
guys to walk by a weight and just lift
weights and get big really quickly I
mean you know I'm saying I'm do some
when you get older it's a little
different yeah but yeah some dudes use a
big funny respond to yeah he's a big
muscular who knows bro yeah who knows
brother brother
yeah depending was that guy holding the
two basketballs
he's hottest and be players that's got
weird let's make it look like that let's
not get to gate well your feet have it's
over free brain you know think like oh
yeah yeah yeah that's not good on this
Roach in Chandler parks do in your off
time hunt you rustle rat Westbrook is
the best should we got some current
events we've obviously run out of things
talk about really not dudes hey man I
don't know about that um do you think
basketball players are the best athletes
yeah
yeah really biggest freaks
yeah I'm start with on the young hard it
is to make because there's only five
slots really well there's 12 meters 12
all right but only five play yeah well
yeah the substitution chillin and it is
a worldwide sport kind of the other the
other nations can't compete with us
really as far as athletics right but you
gotta Ralph let ik yeah no no LeBron
James being born in [ __ ] China yeah
if the speech in Chinese playing how
many Chinese players are playing it's a
huge support over there not many and
then and the NBA I don't think there's
one now what Jeremy Lin was kind of the
hotness for a little bit but he grew up
here in New York so yeah yeah bounce
there boy then you got remember later
Jeremy Lin was Korean no Chinese
[ __ ]
Yao Ming he's not playing anymore Jeremy
Lin yeah he's still playing he's he's
still a really good player but he's just
not like you had that breakout season
this guy's huge he's not playing here
though right here and big weird big so
very they have like just frites up like
the tall guys yeah I don't know how old
come on huh interesting
no a basketball let me look at the
Olympics we [ __ ] Dom if I'm a
competition yeah dominate is would you
say that african-americans are better
they
ever turn it towards basketball yeah
yeah it's not meant I mean yeah Yao
Ming's kind of the poster boy right was
he's still alive but he's [ __ ] huge
weather what is that guy doing man Kiba
tear interesting as the nose on them um
ya mean was [ __ ] good man you read
him it only got [ __ ] dumped on by uh
was it Vince Carter Yami got fight if
you type in yamin dunked on he got
[ __ ] posterized by I think it was
Vince Carter was it Nate Robinson he got
[ __ ] Shakalaka Don Bryant yeah me was
Kobe Bryant
Kobe there's Vince Carter with his nuts
in his face yeah
ya mean works for the Chinese government
in basketball now though he's like the
Ambassador over there
he's enormous he's so big man I don't
think you live very long when you're
that tall oh [ __ ] no his heart is
working overtime
yeah that's a tough no there's he's
bright as three years left let's be real
he's seven the true jerseys now get your
[ __ ] jerseys any ol [ __ ] yelling
shoes you watch it someone else though
lady Kobe nuts in your [ __ ]
face Dwight Howard's like yes please so
Kobe Bryant could dunk I guess he wasn't
just an outside shooter um dude how
about last night some dude brought me a
autographed junior sail card you know I
just want to ask favorite [ __ ] player
yeah yeah that's right
he was I work for an autograph shop like
this off then I kept off the Wow top on
it was like holy [ __ ] dude
pretty cool it's worth a lot then right
I don't know I have no idea
I stopped collecting cards Oh 30 years
ago my friend who is on my show says he
collects pokemon cards how does he know
I'll hold on before he finished it all
he sells them he makes money off yeah
that's fine fantastic house oh but he
may how something like how much he buys
them for and how old is he but but he
does it because it's a no but just give
me like the normal age 30 kids or
anything people buy them when they're
there's a lot you know people trade and
sell coins and shoes and home pokemon
cards a grown man yeah it's a tough sell
bro you can solve for you know a lot if
I was checking for child molesters I'd
be probably the first thing I'd go
towards Pokemon guys that is weird no
Pokemon movies coming out in Ryan
Reynolds is the voice a Pikachu yeah you
know that that's whatever I won't be
seeing that if they know that's a big
role I don't even know Pokemon I don't
know D I know it's [ __ ] enormous I
know that so it's a big role to land
yeah I'll take my son to a Spider Man
tomorrow
yeah once my rents coming out supposed
to be a make cartoon about cartoon like
one of the best movies of the year
really yeah that's cause he's a little
young doesn't he talk and yet in the
fact now dude professional man although
if it's a movie that he likes like we
took them out we took him to wreck-it
Ralph to we took him he's been a bunch
of movie into the spine loves it yeah I
don't copy me though you know cuz not
that's cool though I'm gonna do that dad
today look like tomorrow dude you got a
quick top on Mir oh yeah cool have you
seen it in the trailer I had no idea as
a black kid that's pretty pretty awesome
play it it's pretty dope we get the
trailer that the enemy the reason why
it's cool to me is the animation so much
different than what you've seen before
see that's not your normal animation
I'll take Japanese ish yeah right like
anime almost
annie has Jordan ones on and there's
spider-man addition Jordans coming out
where they look like to join ones but
they have like a web all over them
they're [ __ ] sick that's good then I
look sick there's multiple spider-man's
two men into this spider
there you go huh why there's like six of
them it's really cool
wait a moment it might smite so my son's
gonna love that but he's thank god he's
over [ __ ] Bubble Guppies he's into my
someone through that he's into Teen
Titans Teen teen teen teen titans but I
can watch that they go Teen Titan movie
is so good that's very good man thanks
but thank god did like Bubble Guppies
are like Jesus Christ some amateur
[ __ ] man but Teen Titans actually
really funny thank God Wow
I asked you some strength events is that
Robin that is Robin yeah it's Robins the
leader Robin lawyer cool on this because
he talked about like he just don't want
to be Robin raaaah
no I'm almost cool here this year he's
crazy [ __ ] yeah Robins the man in real
life he got he gets bang he's a
sidepiece bro yeah he's Batman side
piece get my coffee like if Batman Robin
we're podcasting I'd be but Batman you'd
be Robin
what Chin's cat girl no I mean uh cats
cat girl Joker what character would
there's you and me Brian let's be real
and then chins which character chin who
face that reason no he's Dolph really
not funny nope chin would be to face
because he's cool during the day killed
that night it's true we have no idea
what he does half face is a half phaser
to face to face a face you [ __ ] come on
bro no Robins dope though he becomes
Nightwing afterwards and then he becomes
Batman - really yeah it was a good to
face man Tommy thing yeah he's a great
to face look at the makeup on that so
good dude have you seen the trailer for
Clint Eastwood's new movie oh he's you
what does it do on a hundred years old
really really 89 years also done let's
watch put that have you seen it he looks
it looks like on it a carcass is in this
movie yeah he's an old man 89
the mule look at that he's 90 acting
directing [ __ ] that's incredible do
you think you still [ __ ] that mom if I
can make some movies though now Kenny
it's a terrible father yeesh Bradley
Cooper doesn't miss either I can't wait
to see this when's this come out Clint
Eastwood never made a bad movie
no you know some people when they get
older like like like Robert De Niro made
some [ __ ] movies cuz and the money is
the work police would never want that in
his face he's never gone down that way
it becomes a gimmick or you like a
you're so right always like gosh so
[ __ ] right he every movie is [ __ ]
good hard Jim once I come out I will see
that but you know that's so that's I'm
sorry but that that to me like when I
see that I go first of all I have a lot
of work to do second of all or if it
never ends you can all continue to be a
great artist you can continue to be
great at what you do he's 89 doing at
that level that so I comes out this
weekend mm-hmm I can't wait to see that
that's amazing he's so good Wow
Owen Tiffany that you know how he says I
always put work in front I was terrible
father terrible husband all that that
has to come from the inner beast and him
yeah if you know a story and the side
pieces and kids and how much he works
like sometimes I look at like let's be
honest here you look you're like the
rocks Instagram and I see how much he
works I don't work a fraction as much as
that dude man how much time are you at
home with the kiddos yeah no way good
question there's no way I have and then
you see a post every now and then like
look at me and my daughter Mike Brown
you know she said that I started looking
at that that way now I've seen the
wreckage of that that that lifestyle
I've seen it well but we also don't
trust that be also but you also know how
much it takes to be on set the hours it
takes that but then if when you're the
star of the movie or the star of
whatever it
then comes a PR so when you shoot that
movie then you go to the next movie
we'll the works not done have to shoot
the movie then once it releases and
you're the star you do PR not just
you're not just doing radio in LA all
over the world you're gone non-stop do
you know the truth is he prefers that
over everything else
oh I know this yeah no I'm they're
really successful people that I know
whether their business they're not home
by them they they don't really like
doing anything but work at it and it's a
bit of a crew it's an addiction for
narcissus thing but it's they want it
all
because they're so worried about that
flame [ __ ] Deming exactly right but
you know what that doesn't create a good
home life or orchids that are they feel
good about I have a tough time balancing
I'm not and I'm not a [ __ ] fraction
but you know you're home every night I'm
a homebody yeah
I'm a homebody big time like that my
biggest fear is my is is losing touch
and having regret with how I raised my
kids but you're different being your
good dad but you're not a homebody
you're not saying like if you ask me
like but then again I down the town or
you know in a restaurant or home I pick
home 99% of the time for me Amy when my
once my kids go down which is about 8
o'clock I'm out yeah I mean I love you
know once they're down once I know
they're safe and sound spent my time
with them and they're sleeping
see you then you're out yeah yeah yeah
if I don't have stand up I'm not out
yeah there's not a chance I want dinner
I want crowd I want people around me I I
love that me I'm always the same way I
know but that billion there's nothing
wrong with that there's no but I'm if
it's not work dude you're not catching
me I'm not hanging out I'm not getting
drinks I like to be home in my sweats
watching TV man Netflix
yeah something yeah there's the Haunted
potatoes nothing rhyming yeah it's good
better to be but we're kind of not with
the new house about anyways but with the
but also I checked the box as far as why
the work I do is with my friends they're
like this is our work I know by 9:00
last night last night
comstor I did three sets but you know
I'm on stage for a total of maybe 45
minutes total for the whole night but
other than that I'm there with Rogan
best friend Brian best friend Kristy Lee
at best I mean I'm there with my boys in
the back that checks the boxes I don't
need to see you guys tomorrow night I'm
good you get your you can see guys every
week three guys off let's do it through
works we're good man yeah and it's not
work I was thinking obviously and this
isn't why I was thing about this last
night dreamt from the Comi store this in
a it's very rare for me to acknowledge
us this is the best time in my entire
life yesterday when we were being silly
I go
we were walking Brendan Brendan we had
to go through this long crowd right
comic store packed every night
and they're coming to see us as we're
walking through I'm doing this - Brendan
I'm going UFC jobs trying to borrow your
awesome bro you're awesome UFC he's like
shut the [ __ ] up on my blog about
fighter indicated they're like holy [ __ ]
Brian counts cat calling Brennan this
guy in the crowd anyway lost ours there
I go hey dude as we're walking were
laughing and then we're going to see all
our friends until there's an idiot with
this pink sweatshirt and [ __ ] on and
I go hey do you MIT don't you miss
fighting don't you miss those days would
you rather be a comedian to be the best
time I've done some cool [ __ ] man but
right now as far as hey you know I'm in
throw-up 35 you know I'm [ __ ] fine
answering some everything's all good no
stress comedy great my friends are great
kids great my girls great my life for 35
I wasn't I know I've never been happier
it's crazy man which is very rare for me
to acknowledge 35 I was auditioning and
not getting auditions and working
periodically and I wasn't doing the
right thing this is the best time -
Brian yeah cuz that cuz so much of my
30s were so hard cuz I was trying to be
an actor and not a cop you're trying to
figure it out I was just trying to be an
actor and not be a comic and I worked
and stuff I always worked but it just
wasn't it was there's a struggle city
and Oh Bobo failure failure failure
tough no money and then forties for
when it started really up to the
hangover maybe I can't remember no I was
always working and I did know you know
he's gonna work I did a lot you know was
always work and I always working but you
were never but it wasn't serious I was
always like it was always like you know
like you wanna easy yeah I was always
money was always life in yeah that's
life I always made money I always done
ever had but I but it was never what
that's the life yeah like you're and
stand up but we are performing when
you're professional actor
unless you're the one of 1% yeah like
you're and they hit me the other day
with this like with I'm growth you buy a
new house in Psych when you're on the
road like when you're a comic like that
that that's what pays the bills man like
you're that's how you make your living
my road looks I got to get to this nut
it's like oh I gotta go tell these jokes
so they pay me for that so you can pay
for this yeah he's not and the road for
me for a long time was very it was great
I loved it but it was hard selling
tickets it was small rooms it was all
that stuff so so much of that was you
know I'd be there from Wednesday to
Sunday I'd be there from Wednesday to
Monday buy out Wednesday dude Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday [ __ ] how bad you
want it you know I mean I did that for
years that's a dog that's a dog and you
come back and you audition you're single
at the time right yeah but not always no
I did that well no I'm just saying you
didn't have your wife and kids at the
time mmm for a while your Wednesday to
Sunday - I didn't not - you know if
you're in podunk [ __ ] Northern
California I won't call it any cities
and you're there on a Sunday for four
first you already think your entire
first four years of my daughter's life I
did that that's tough it was tough it
sucked and I and and it it it costs it
weighed heavily on especially my wife
Mike Mike that's how it goes
I [ __ ] had tears in my eyes this
morning because Mike my kid I went to
Disneyland with my girl and he's well I
didn't know this
he had a growth spurt right and so now
he's tall enough to go on the cars ride
at Disneyland which he's obsessed with
cars and I've always been like tamo and
taking on that but they're always like -
sure and I come on I'm hope hopefully
the guy working there noticed me and
there's like I go ahead
authorities I can't man he just he's not
there yet and then my girl [ __ ] sends
me a video of him on the ride and dude I
saw you in tears - I'm Akay [ __ ]
missed it man yeah I [ __ ] missed it
and I'll show you the video what it's I
mean time of his life everyone I miss I
saw both my kids walk for the first time
and sometimes when you're in the
military or whatever and you're gone for
that long you miss those things that's
all right dude you want to make me tear
up you play those [ __ ] military guys
coming home I cry over there kid
I think I think Chelsea bring up Chelsea
Handler you're ready to [ __ ] I can't
Wetworks know Chelsea hey I think Sarah
Silverman reposted Chelsea Handler you
probably go Sarah Silverman's I know
it's hers for a fax on our Instagram
yeah it's it yeah that the troop ones I
can't dude I can't imagine ones her I
can't I can't imagine doing that and
being gone for 3-4 months if I go on the
road even if I can't I just go god bless
those [ __ ] boots right here right
here right here all right
turn that [ __ ] up those you're just
listening to podcast it's a troop
waiting out the door of his house and
his son answers cool when you have kids
the whole world changes like that all
you want them to be as happy man look at
that [ __ ] what a good little cool little
boy if you have kids man out there don't
please be with that man don't you know
fathers and people to just leave their
kids you can't do that to your kid
you'll regret it I don't give a [ __ ] who
you are you will regret it it's the word
it's one of the worst sins you can do
just be they're not your most important
job on this [ __ ] planet man it is man
when you when you when you're not there
for your kids when you ignore them and
stuff like that they feel it deeply then
you're a piece of [ __ ] if you do that it
doesn't or maybe there maybe you're
maybe you don't think you have enough to
offer maybe you
you're they better off without you
you're wrong you're [ __ ] wrong you're
wrong you're wrong shout out to Sarah
Silverman still smoking by the way yeah
by the way and still hilarious hilarious
I would say the best female atomic right
I mean you probably wouldn't get an
argument from it and you can say top
five of all time percent right
I said Silverman 1% her last special I
thought was she's so good
huge fan yeah alright let's give some
current events before we start crying
and keep their videos okay speaking of
the NBA in an interview Steph Curry Iggy
and Vince Carter all said that they
don't believe that the moon landing
actually happened so they don't think
we've ever been to the moon or they
don't know Neil Armstrong landed no they
don't think we've ever been to the moon
they think it was all manufactured and
and and and then they go why haven't we
gone back so let's just go through this
so I had an astrophysicist come to my
show in Albuquerque yeah and yeah the
little JIT dude you know like that's his
job yeah she didn't play in the NBA I
know those guys know a lot about space
travel I know they do
and also jet propulsion all those things
that's their job when they're not
shooting free-throws but keep going yes
so he goes we were talking about Flat
Earth on stuff he goes oh dude me and my
colleagues in our cubicle when Brian and
Eddie and you guys going back forth to
goes word on the floor and laughing at
how stupid some the comments are he goes
it makes our day here's I hope they
never stop talking about conspiracy
because socially flat earth egos there's
nothing he goes there couldn't be an
easier point to prove for us because
it's so easy and comical and then I go
it's so I go dude what about the moon
and goes what about it Brian did I go
well have we land on egos of course we
have and I go but was it Neil Armstrong
goes that I can't validate I don't know
but I can guarantee we've been in the
moon and I go then why haven't we been
back yours because there's nothing there
that's no reason for us to get very
experienced we've checked it it's very
expensive get there there's a lot of
resources and Mars are over he goes
we're going elsewhere where there's more
capabilities of life and bigger things
to research and finders there's nothing
we're not check this thing out with this
guy's own fake dobro and he
you tell those astrophysical a go yeah
maybe it took to the thousand plus
people to put them on the moon more than
that the biggest on their all line yeah
they're all I knew everybody and they
all they were all killed you know
they're all killed they're all killed
they go why because they're born in the
twenties the hardest thing would be to
try to actually pull something like that
off in the government what they'll be
out by now I'm kidding me be out by now
what are you talking about but that's
people who know nothing about it science
you don't knowing about how the
government works you know they think
they do but some would some of the
conspirators like JFK 100% I've looked
into that enough where there's so much
shady is going on I can't tell you who
did it I don't have any facts but it but
it's women smoke there's a little fire
on symbol that's something there's a lot
of factor you know there are things we
don't find the moon
there's no argument now the only
argument you I think you could legit
make it did me with me are showing the
exact guy I don't know that gets a
little shady but that we did go with it
I don't even think that gets Shady why
would they wide me why would they yeah
somebody was on the moon for sure 100%
yeah the flat earth is ridiculous the
moon
JFK i [ __ ] with if you talking about
Sandy Hook I'll punch you in the dick
I don't know obviously that really
happened September 11th
my problem this is my problem September
11th is people who I value their
judgment more than anyone say when you
look into September 11 if there is a
little bit of shadiness absolutely not
not know and hold on not as far as it
all going down and people dying in
flying to the building but the people
who did it and people who were behind it
it's like they say it's not as easy
saying oh it's Osama bin Laden well he
he was in charge of all of it he did it
kill him and we're good well nobody
saying no no no there's way it goes way
more in yeah well there is which that's
where there is a group of people that
did this but if you the looming tower
Lawrence Wright won a Pulitzer Prize for
the looming tower which is an in-depth
he's an investigative journalist and
in-depth look interviews who they caught
what they said I mean this is all a
matter of record and involves thousands
of law enforcement people it doesn't
involve so so the idea we know that we
know that al-qaeda was doing this on a
smaller
the Khobar towers the USS Cole etc etc
no al-qaeda 100 centers yeah Roger but
they're saying that there's links to
where they were his hearing by the US
government disagree more
but the biggest the biggest conspiracy
to me was when that the real conspiracy
was when the Bush administration tied
Saddam Hussein to al-qaeda to justify
the Iraq invasion that was a lie
that was a conspiracy see but don't you
think the government's will do that be
just feel yeah if they're run to
negotiate there a little bit with
conspiracy JFK we knows a little bit
conspiracy is it but I think that's your
grab far-fetched to say there was
something with September 11th or no so
so no because I don't I don't have an
argument that there are people in the
governess would work so there are people
in government knew that a group of
fanatics we're going to take down the
World Trade Center it embarrassed the
CIA that embarrassed our intelligence a
but some people made a lot of money from
it though didn't they money how is it
money's always made money's always made
off of war that is a big problem but
that's always been the case you only had
war profiteers with people who sell arms
and all the raw materials and everything
else of course but there's fighting
there's money in the industrial the
military-industrial complex and for the
percent which is a huge problem but it's
never that organized right these are
things that build momentum the idea that
there are certain CIA guys that set this
up and then they put charges in towers
that this stuff is so crazy nobody's
it's you didn't you it's way more likely
that a group of fanatics flew planes
into the building's agree right I mean
that's what happens it no but I think
finaiiy i think fanatics flew planes
into the building's but in order for
them to do that and to get those steps
and the planes everything to get there I
do think they had some sort of help now
I'm not saying it's from our government
officials
I'm not saying it's from the Bush
campaign I don't know yeah but I do
think they had some sort of help I don't
think there's you said to me for example
that
that Ariel Sharon and Israel
intelligence might have known that did
this is very cynical but if you said the
Israelis may have had information that a
an attack was imminent on the World
Trade Center and there was a small group
of intelligence agent elevators they say
wait guys this would be good cuz we can
pin it on Iraq
take out the fourth largest army the
Middle East that's a threat to Israel
and then we can go after Iran I would
say oh I can see that happening I can
see that you would think along those
lines right that kind of stuff can can
sometimes make some sense you know hey
would you would you be opposed to having
triply unharness talking some
conspiracies well that was lovely I love
trip I think it'd be fun to talk about
cuz he he has his black belt and
conspiracies and he'll talking about it
I find it interesting I don't believe
all of it but some of it I do when it
comes to you know certain things I I can
be [ __ ] kind of open-minded when
certain things but I think it'd be good
to have money just without your too
funny my only issue is that there's
never been any evidence that was C so
does there's overwhelming emphasis so
but but but the evidence that there was
a conspiracy that the u.s. government
and involved with all the investigative
journalists we have all of them with all
those people that we have like who are
who are interested in exposing the US
government cuz a lot of journalists
could give a [ __ ] about the US
government sure that's a giant amorphous
blob and they would they would make
their career on finding the people
responsible right mm-hmm
we haven't had any of that yet but is
that easy that amazing but it is easy to
chalk up that just like I'll see Hillary
Clinton has in the Clintons have some
shade behind all out some of its out not
everything we know so much mother clouds
right know about white water I know but
some of its out but don't you think
there's things we don't know there's
only there's no way we don't we know
everything that the Clintons have done
there's always a little evil there's
always things we don't know but but the
idea that by JFK yeah but there's spin
so the government has [ __ ] files that
they really saw some of them but Trump
goes I can't release these other ones
because
it's gonna cause [ __ ] frenzy in the
public eye so we gotta keep that's what
he said he released a shitload of
numbers Trump say but he goes but he was
advised not to release all of it I I
think that I I don't think that the
government so when you say the
government these large in this large
entity I just don't believe that the
government's that are organized I just
don't
and every time they try to pull it off
they get they get exposed and and I you
don't think there's things that with the
wheel I know you're investing something
I think I think they're investigative
journalists who have deep contacts
within the deep state who had their
contacts in the CIA FBI and all the
difference in tells you think you'd be
out by now well they all have content
but not all of it they all and and
people intelligence agencies don't they
compete with each other they're not all
loyal no they're not all about all we'd
love to get the truth out I agree and so
with all that and all the journalists
who follow this so closely like Lawrence
Wright in these people who really spent
their life doing it not one credible
journalist that you that we read and you
know that they pick them anybody let
just pick the pick the thousands of
journalists that work for cannot the
economists for the New York Post for the
New York Times who would love to expose
the truth which they do all the time and
embarrass the intelligence agencies all
the time they would love to find this
true it's not one of them has come
forward their evidence I have to go
well that's because there is no evidence
there you think we yeah you don't think
there's anything we don't know you think
it's just all out and open those
journals would find it that's insane
that's a different question
but that's about that's a crazy to think
that they would uncover it and I'm
saying is that I believe that a group
called al-qaeda organized and executed I
do to be no mean you insane but I think
they had help from from certain
resources I don't think they pulled it
all off on them if they had help from
certain resources I believe those
resources might have been Saudi Arabia
those resources could be elements may be
these are all elements that have vested
interest so the Pakistani intelligence
services Pakistan is an ally of ours
right but the is is I think it's called
it was done hiding him so so so a lot of
those but so suits are what I'm saying
is that the the Pakistani we give a lot
of money to Pakistan intelligence
agencies to stop terrorism right we also
know that the
Pakistani intelligence agency harbors
some of the worst Taliban perpetrators
of violence against American troops we
know that the Haqqani network for
example is is harbored in a pie that was
Ariston that sort of hinterland Pakistan
Pakistani protected airspace so we know
that they're not our allies we know that
they have a vested interest in
continuing certain conflicts in for
example Afghanistan because they make
money off it to get monies why was Osama
bin Laden found I think it was a mile
away from Pakistan's version of West
Point Oh what do I know you think they
know that he was there of course they
knew he do protect you nothing if they
make so much money off I know
do you not think so yes the answer is
just no one raised an eyebrow to Osama
bin Laden they go dump them in the ocean
bro we don't have evidence we don't have
his body so so do one of the reasons
they did that one of the reasons I know
they don't put up a mosque at all no you
know what you want a shrine where people
go to it that's all they betrayed you
know things okay to me I do black John
Hill for me but I believe he's
assassinated because you had so many you
had such a huge operation and all those
SEAL team guys there that'd be a hard
thing to keep secret no no no I think he
was killed
yeah a hundred I think he's dead I just
find it a little interesting how I think
there was a lot of liber8 decision that
was made but you can see and I'm not
conspirators but you can see other like
come on like they're feeding those
trolls yes the trolls like come on but
it wasn't the bed the [ __ ] ocean was
decided by committee and a group and
they said where do we bury him what do
we do bury and here's the thing to your
point a committee who is much smarter
than us yeah
who went no no we're not bringing his
body back to the States and people get
known yeah when I can deliver him back
to where the [ __ ] he's from put him in
[ __ ] sea no one's gonna see this [ __ ]
ever again that's right that's right
I've never seen the video of it if it's
Obama and he's [ __ ] sitting there
like this and they're in the room
they're watching the seals on a [ __ ]
oh yeah ah yeah on of TV while they're
performing this Yushin cuz his like
whole legacy is pretty riding on this
being could've been
sass and the plane goes down the
helicopter goes down to remember there
or watch it you can there do you even
just like can there be I get chills
rooms could there be a more we get
[ __ ] Hillary Clinton could there be a
more intense situation ever as a
president were you green light to go get
[ __ ] Osama bin Laden and your wife
you're watching it yes and you can see
he's literally like Jesus Christ look at
[ __ ] Hillary Clinton look at Obama
back there dude crazy
can you imagine [ __ ] going to bed
that night knowing the plan tomorrow is
to go [ __ ] seek out the number one
terrorist in the world and you green let
this thing and then you get a watch it
on TV yeah yeah you you Intel he's just
like dear I bet his nerves were on [ __ ]
you know it's real stakes are crazy I
bet no sleep that night yeah I bet zero
sleep well they said we found them and I
think they found throughout that
Pakistani doctor they got DNA they
matched it correct and if you watch 30
they those guys got in trouble because
so much that was accurate
yep that's like you're showing us
they'll get the whole room there though
man God get in that the ER Intelligence
Agency is creative they come up with
creative ways to catch bad guys and they
have all the resources in the world and
at the CIA of the FBI's after you it's a
matter of time there could not be a
worth I always talk about this and they
they work with British intelligence
right good luck it was not good I would
talk about this one whenever watch any
of those shows or I love all Navy SEALs
[ __ ] yeah any stretch force thing if you
are a criminal or you're a bad person
and the [ __ ] US government's on your
ass joy that you're so [ __ ] it's not
how I'm gonna get cotton into no not
they're gonna [ __ ] the Brit on Gotland
yard and and mi5 and mi6 enjoy that good
luck have a guy like Tim Kenney on your
case where he his life is depend on
finding you navigate in Kenny's trying
to find you yeah but also the all the
brilliant people all the computer people
all those those nerds oh why because
they're the smartest people in America
like who who have their black belting
climbing your job and hot you're getting
caught you're gonna get caught you your
self and your
and it's off even that's a us said even
the cartel members say we know it's a
matter we're gonna get caught we all
know how did this lie well you're gonna
get caught advanced cartel them you're
gonna die what do you think you're
flying to the radar of our government no
no they're only letting me get away with
what they want you right now till they
go what oh yeah yeah that's all right
let's go after that yeah as soon as you
get their attention where it's big
enough here
[ __ ] it's never worked out for anyone
ever in the history of a man my father
said who has some experience with you
know intelligence my father after 9/11
he is very common and I said you seem so
calm and he said well I know you don't
believe this now but you're going to
forget about this or you're gonna go on
with your life and when you're going on
with your life a lot of people are gonna
be just getting started on evening this
score actually said to me he goes long
after and when you go back whether this
is very hot for you and this is very
emotional for you and this is New York
and you have friends that were you know
and he said when you are back to your
life there were people there are people
who will be just getting into the thick
of this so they're just getting ready
oh you rattled the [ __ ] US of a
special-forces let's slip hold that
hornet's nest and they go scuse me a--
nothing makes me more proud oh my god it
gives me chills yeah there's such
[ __ ] battle is that one general Togo
I think it was or he radioed back after
they burned bombed Pearl Harbor and said
how'd it go he goes it went well you
ever woke in a sleeping giant we were in
trouble no one better either their [ __ ]
in the United States is a beautiful idea
yeah it is when I was in New York we
drove by the the new the freedom towers
and you know New York Chili's been like
I've never got the how people are so in
love with infatuated with New York and
this last trip I did I finally kicked me
like god it's a [ __ ] great city man
there's so much cool [ __ ] here obviously
there's a ton of people aren't like that
many people in one spot either way it's
amazing [ __ ] City I get it now I
couldn't live there but I [ __ ] get
not going there and when we drove by the
freedom towers yeah I I was like I can't
[ __ ] imagine dudes were right there
where people were running see the videos
I can't
II mean I still I can't imagine I used
to walk behind you what if people sick
because there's people it's busy and you
just in the road there's vendors there's
pizza and shopping and cars and then I
can't understand they're going what the
[ __ ] is that it was the ah it was
honestly dude it was the unimaginable I
used to walk by those buildings for two
years every day and the the it was the
feet of Manhattan
it was the feet of Manhattan I grew up
we all grew up with those those were
such a huge part of New York you know it
was it was I'm not an emotional guy but
that was too much for me to bear you
know happened it was it was truly too
much for me to bear when it happened and
Jimmy Burke - he came to New York he
couldn't get back to New York he was in
San Francisco he flew to LA and he was
crying into his meal [ __ ] watching
crying yeah too much that was know when
you drive by it you're like what oh yeah
[ __ ] I was very tough very tough man
it's so crazy man yeah thanks Stephen
Curry keep Stefan curry you guys are
awesome at basketball what else you got
so a family in Texas went to Sonics to
have a meal and they found a next and
ecstasy pill in the kids meal the worker
was probably down for party and just
dropped it in there or they perfect it
seemed to deliberate holy so they had
two kids with them a four year old and
an eleven year old the eleven year old
girl was unwrapping the hamburger to try
to help feed her sibling found the
little pill and asked her mom if it was
candy the mom said don't eat that they
took it to the police station they found
out it was xst they went back to the
Sonics investigated arrested three
people and the woman in the middle was
actually found with 3x2 ecstasy pills on
her when she got arrested idiot man
mm-hmm
sometimes humans a bum me out as far as
I was about our forces and our troops
then you go to [ __ ] idiots here's the
thing though okay so you give these
toddlers ecstasy then they go home you
know
see any of it would okay okay that's
your goal that's what the [ __ ] your plan
was cool man
yeah you [ __ ] morons Lisa wasn't acid
just like let's make sure I stay great
it's so weird man what else you got so
two nuns are accused of embezzling five
hundred thousand dollars from a school
that they worked at it's great okay yeah
it's a gamble in Las Vegas they took it
from the kids tuition money did they win
no word on whether that matter did they
doubled their money and then bring it
back right in school I'm not I'm not
that mad at this I'm not happy I knew a
guy who used to steal money from the
restaurants safe he used to work at and
he would bet on baseball and kicked ass
and would always win and then then then
he lost and then he put the money back
in one weekend he went and to better
than a bunch of stuff and when he got
back there away for him him and they
were like he goes bad luck for me I
guess and what happened to him they
fired him do you know arrested he always
put the money back so he's like robbing
arrest him you think Robin Hood did yeah
but they're like you can't maybe we
can't have that lease you you know I
thought least he's a good guy about it
he's good just taken and just [ __ ] da
yeah but what else you got I don't know
if you guys want to talk about this one
this one's a sad one yeah so there was a
video that went viral where NYPD
officers are taking away a child from a
mother and there's one police officer
who gets really aggressive and starts
pulling the child stars what puling the
child like physically just like trying
to pull him without any weld or we do it
it was this woman abusing the child what
was the deal so what happened was she
was at a HR building or something she
was trying to collect a daycare voucher
for her son and it took several hours
there were no seats to open so she went
ahead and sat on the floor the workers
asked her to please stand or leave she
said she wasn't gonna stand and she
wasn't going to leave so they called
police officers police officers were
trying to get her off
the premises and when things got
escalated they started to try to
physically take her out of the building
and they started trying to take the
child away from her to get her out and
there was one officer who got buried
rowdy yeah a little-little - a granny
even the Commissioner that the Chief of
Police can was like that's not though
it's not going let's not rip a trial no
the chief goes to cheat the chief of
police goes there's ways to deal with
this and that's not the way you go we
should be de-escalating the situation
yeah not escalating how about sitting
next to her and just talking about
yeah how about just going me like you
mean come on like yeah exactly talk to
her you don't need to [ __ ] do there
was a ball so is she hurting anyone
is it she obstructing justice by sitting
on the floor with her child there might
be a way for the staff we don't need
police are coming any animal yeah that's
a terrible there's a guy there's a dog
that had been abused and was really mean
pitbull and they're like well we're
gonna put it down I guess hold it
no just relax you see him sit and open
his lunch the dog had game he starts
eating his lunch you [ __ ] get the
Baga higher hey is that chicken of the
sea look is that how you go but him
check him out to it or thought that
state you know and so he's just eating
in and the dogs like ah and he just kind
of goes just goes he just takes a little
piece and just kind of Chuck's it behind
him done
yeah and the next thing you know a
[ __ ] he's feeding the dog out of his
hand
okay that's great tired dog and then
they put it down anyway that is not so
fast you got a fat belly yeah yeah then
they stopped it can't have that yeah
yeah so Peter released a statement
saying that they want people to stop
saying things like bring home the bacon
showing two birds with one stone he
thanks Peter and no and you guys get
along with that girl from Princeton it
does it who thinks kiss the girl is
offensive do ya did you see the
recommendations
yeah the feed you can't feed a dog
dianna animal language Oh super through
one sound feed two birds with one skull
dude if you said that I would punch you
in the face be the guinea pig beat it if
you if you looked at me and if I went
dude let's kill two birds with one stone
man this is easy win whoa bro let's feed
two birds with one skull I would grab
your nuts beat a dead horse feed a fed
horse be the guinea pig be the test to
bring home the bacon bring home the
bagels take the bull by the horns take
the flour by the thorn well no man baka
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you PETA actually
celebrate what they represent my arms
are part of their foundation but [ __ ]
you PETA whatever I mean I like I mean I
understand that can you imagine every
that right no come on can you imagine if
you came right to it dude come on don't
beat a dead horse and if you if I went
bro
you mean feet of fed horse your friends
like dude get out go ahead and get out
for me why it's at weight about God I do
think that they I do think that factory
factory farming I do understand you like
people who some people just have like
like I've dated people who have had deep
deep feeling for animals like I
absolutely love they're so tasty human
amol like no but that day I [ __ ] love
them but I'm not I'm not killing
anything by going dude don't be yeah
I'll be the guinea pig no I know come on
I know you're not but they're so
delicious they are tasty man you ever
eat horse meat no no I I love them I
understand I feel sometimes you want you
wanna focus on something that would
change the the culture we live in and I
in affect humans how about when we say
stop being gay don't be a [ __ ] right like
that that is something you want to focus
on yeah that's right that's that might
be something cuz that's like a vanilla
that it just somehow if you're in
youtube comment Instagram comment if you
post anything that's even a little
touchy people go that's gay right how
much if you're gay not what's yeah yeah
I think these people are kind of in the
same I think what's gonna happen is when
we come up with meat that doesn't suffer
right so we can clone meat and create
meat without a care
Patty's like $97,000 but when they can
scale that I think we're gonna look back
on what we did to animals and go Jesus
back in the day we used to kill animals
how [ __ ] up I get it you know maybe
they're more evolved than I am no but
also like that's the that's the nature
of the business I mean so let's say we
killed no animals do you know what our
plan it would look like if you just left
all animals but we breed so many animals
before slaughter is environmental hazard
there's a lot of problems yeah there's a
lot the whole situate the whole
industries [ __ ] up but we need
protein but when we can when we can grow
good good quality meat without suffering
I mean I'm hauling yeah hundred percent
I do not want to kill anyone else have
you guys tried that burger that
impossible burger I heard it's really
good heard it's good too I never tried a
boy taught film and swears by it what is
it it's just it's fake me it's fake meat
but it looks like a real piece a Tanner
supposed to be really really good
protein animal foods looks really feed
it to me but don't tell me it's fake
that's what I would like what's in it
I'll go back look at that go back to the
look go back to the article says the
science behind it see the see the video
yeah let's see what the [ __ ] going on
here baby I love when I see seeds on a
bun this one was created in a lab it's
called the impossible burger and it's
100% made from plants was this the boys
host on Planet [ __ ] earth makes you
not want it do you don't you make you
want to kill a cow in Richard Brown what
Richard isn't a fashion okay so the
brain can't tell the difference which is
bad burger the problem is you can you
imagine what a siphon with here can you
imagine be on the side so you're eating
a very fake something well today that of
cheesy
what old people crackers she time I
write Oh smells sugar called he and it
looks and tastes like blood I might just
take your meat you know that's pretty
crazy though kind of want to try one now
do I [ __ ] my pants in an hour is it
laughter that because you're not gonna
feel great I think between a beef burger
and be impossible
it's beef protein potato protein I mean
wheat protein scientists causes
allergies it could be it could be tough
on your stomach yeah I'm worried about
it with my psoriasis I'll try I'll be
the guinea pig I'll order us to all be
the test two and todd todd Feldman
swears by it yeah he loves him he went
vegan for a while I didn't talk to him
Todd to the shape I didn't talk to him
out it'd be good for a while and you
know this Todd but he's in shape oh yeah
you know he hits mitts with a Glenn like
every day now yeah we got all right what
else we got
he's a [ __ ] good guy and he's a real
friend yeah that's fun yeah yeah I know
Todd felm is there is like monster agent
at CAA like this huge agent top three
and he's the biggest thing he's like a
super agent well my best friend and and
he's Todd Phillips agent Todd Phillips
swears by him he's just a great guy
David that [ __ ] is the most
loyal I know this for a fact he's the
most loyal friend and puts himself out
for oh why because my his my my son when
he was going through the the seizures
and I was like I called him if I have an
issue I call him he's like my he's your
call him he's your rabbi my guy man yeah
and I go dude and they tell me that CBD
oil can help within an hour at my house
I had the best CBD oil on the planet
lost two [ __ ] vials of it yeah he had
it flown over to my [ __ ] house he
goes give him this he's something I
don't find a better CBD and it worked
yeah how crazy is that just he's just a
very special dude which is rare I feel
like [ __ ] in rare what do you mean yet
to be that generous and that caring and
that success in it well I was gonna say
that powerful yeah
powerful talking he's like he could tell
everybody to [ __ ] off and yet
and he's a real beautiful is it
beautiful all right what else we got
show Todd Feldman Tom in UFC canceled
the Anaheim card you have c 233 which is
a pretty stacked card did they say why
they canceled it they didn't say why but
everyone's saying because there's also
the Bellator heavyweight tournament in
that same weekend the TJ Dillashaw a
pseudo was moved toward so just a bunch
of different things
yeah you know that's one that Ben Askren
supposed to be fighting on with Robbie
Lawler yep any supposed to be on below
the belt that week well there you go
they're just moving it forward I heard
some there motherboard in Anaheim though
or somewhere I don't know so they're
worried about pay-per-views that's
what's going on and selling all right
all right why don't you get one more MMA
thing that we were talking about this on
blow the belt so Brock Lesnar for
whatever reason in Asada's website
showed that he had two tests and then it
magically disappeared like later on
someone found out about one of the tests
disappearing and then who thought I made
an statement saying that it was just a
technical issue that it wasn't even
supposed to be there in the first place
right and then the guy who looked this
up this guy dim space said he looked at
every other fighter on the on the
registry and that this is the only
fighter word this technical issues time
never happy huh I don't listen when
you're in business to Brock Lesnar I'm a
big Brock Lesnar fan I think's
phenomenal fighter he yeah it's you're
dealing with shady business you do some
kind of some shady business that's the
that's the game you play with him and
Nowitzki also said he has access to all
the database stuff and he goes yeah I
would have seen this and it was never
there in the first place
it seemed super super Sheen vixie works
for them so that's that you know yeah
okay okay I'll have a problem with it
alright cool min alright and I'm a huge
Nowitzki fan but it is what it is man
it's what it is shady be Shady let Brock
do his [ __ ] man hey you see this hockey
player hockey ref so hockey player shot
up hit a puck and the puck reflected off
the refs didn't actually land it into
the goal this bar has to be barstools
this bar - no but it was on I might say
unfortunate free dicks
his Deadspin they talk about Eugene I'm
assuming refs don't hit we're cups I
mean they probably should I imagine they
would if they're doing this just didn't
see it boom and then shove it right into
the goal it doesn't count though there's
there's a rule in there that's bullsh
you know because maybe what if they keep
you are sucking now they're gonna start
yeah if they do that must have [ __ ]
heart
yeah I wish that happen to you chin I
just want you thanks feel it not to be
mean I wish you just I've been hit with
a ball I just haven't been kicked mm-hmm
without eventually this is just an
interesting stuff from pornhub oh yeah
boy Alex sent sent us this right yeah
the same guy pornhub who came to my show
right he worked for pornhub gave me
pornhub hats and teachers oh I can't
where I was like I know I'm not wearing
a pornhub no the search is that if I do
I make my loyal follower yes stormy
Daniels number one on pornhub yeah you
know what I looked her up myself I want
to see who's [ __ ] bro yeah I tried
talking for I didn't but I'm gluten I
sucked a very good dick really yeah
she's hot man god bless
yep fortnight yeah weird right weird for
K than romantic is that number for
brands number five and the people that
search trans is more interesting so well
so interest interest in trans ek
transgender porn saw significant gains
done eighteen in particular with flutter
sixty-seven percent increase in searches
by men and more than two hundred with
visitors over the age of forty five 164
been doing as much when you [ __ ] as
much as a guy like Borel Bry has you get
bored you know just regular girls mmm I
might I need to shake things up I need a
[ __ ]
well I don't know I you know that so you
just need to switch it up I don't know
what I think what uh scroll oz it Oh
what what the [ __ ] is Bose Eddie
Bose upset I don't know does it say what
it Oh said both set is that good girl
the bone here it is life who takes are
da Vinci porn imitates everything so
perhaps it's no surprise see that both
I'll submit our list of search that
defined to an 18 at the original
Nintendo fan art went viral searches for
broke exceeds three million just one
reason it's there was a cap there's a
character and mario party named bowser
he's the dinosaur somebody made an
animation of him as a girl and it was
like a sexy girl and that went viral so
I think there's a quick look so this is
an animation porn so both sets gets five
Bowser Bowser oh wow I kind of see those
are about that chind is any video yeah
we can go on porn up I'm sure let me see
Belle said bro did you just wait you
know it's weird why I will never never
understand ever how people jack off to
cartoons I just not my no I cannot stand
literally name anything else that
involves a breathing human being I get
it man
I can see how you're into that cartoons
I just know she's in cosplay so that's
like a role-playing thing oh we should
watch that but there's some animated
stuff right there
yeah let me see that chin oh there's a
compilation of evidence where work let's
go see the bow that someone that comes
come you Asian yeah there you just let
me just I've never seen dude that's
[ __ ] okay it's still not my thing
though like set of tits on herself
that's forward a little [ __ ] as I saw
one thing I did kind of turn me on
wow those are some Hauser's tit Oh
babies
TIG ol bitties bro I don't care why
people like this man I guess they're
showing two cartoons that day it comes
over to the sexual side too because it
did show the girl from I've always
wanted peace of Jessica Rabbit Jessica
Rabbit I love her like that kind of
music and when they thumb is it crazy
cute virus here's a virus good alright
it's ever stalled like this
her own she has a tail and they actually
bleeped it out for some reason except
for an [ __ ] this does it like that
doesn't do anything I guess is real porn
I'd probably have a bit of a job doesn't
do a thing whoa whoa okay that one I can
kind of understand tailed it she's a
tail boner here changes color and she
has a turtle back - ah guys but I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] about a tail on
girl spikey I don't care you know I mean
if you look like that I'll put up with
like ah I got a big tail so what that
that's so weird - man I cannot for the
life of me understand it it's
interesting fetish fetish fetish porn
yeah a little tail so they have turtle
shows and Tails alright Wow well sex
there you go
that's a weird passion of mine Bowser
Bowser pop-ups later
those are super interesting man trans
number five that's interesting yeah have
you guys seen the video of the trans
Instagram model trained to recreate
Victoria Secrets Christmas you know
terms for to an eighteen lesbian I I
don't know you guys anymore I don't
[ __ ] know you guys anymore mom what's
not Thai that's hentai that's uh that's
Japanese animation porn we're liking big
then huh yeah it's like they can't have
like an animation of a penis showing so
they use tentacles no no no big ass is
down [ __ ] you guys man Korean is up
sixteen Ebony's middle what's wrong with
you asian okay up six [ __ ] boxing with
that Japanese up three mom down one okay
let me see this trans doing the [ __ ]
we want to eat absolutely you look tired
dude shooting and yet
you're out late last night with me told
ya
one-thirty I got stage late are you home
at 1:00 I did it quick so what the
hell's going in here she's trans yep
she's trans Asians make the best trans
girl say - holy did she have a [ __ ] and
balls no she's a girl Brennan take it
easy what I think she fully transitioned
when she made this after the board
member at Victoria's Secret said that
trans woman couldn't sell the fantasy
Wow hands honor though you're not
feeling it chin the face looks to like
there's just too much work done to the
face that's obvious yeah still though
give her a little break do you know what
else we working with Jojo Wow look at
that face looks weird between her and
her friend but she kind of looked like
that if you keep scrolling down there's
a different photo she kind of looked
like that before yeah well you know but
it changes well is it coming up damn she
is a boyfriend hopefully yeah this is oh
[ __ ] look down to the right well she's
it well yeah yeah look so tough on them
yeah okay you know it's the face does
look like it's his normal face her
normal face does yeah she's got a nose
job clearly the lid knows for sure she
had her lips done on the left their eyes
look smaller that's just makeup yeah
now Brian's energy has left the entire
building I can tell when you have low
energy yeah I just had yeah you've been
out all day all night yeah yeah and I
just lost a little my energy that's fine
well you get your dick on Jackie I'm
talking about food and I'm excited I
know Jax up this training for us all
right
bus like we have that sugar fish in a
long time we shouldn't sugar fish and a
slice it's too much yeah oh is that it
those are good guys thank you guys
anything else be but sit before you lose
all energy in your body um no I'm good
fantastic man a few dates for you guys
I'm at the Ice House in Pasadena Bryan
won't be with me with some other funny
people well Bryan will be in Africa but
December 28th through the 29th I'm at
the Ice House in Pasadena run my full
hour after that January only two dates
in January all I'm in Edmonton Canada
January 10th through the 12th and then
San Diego she's my one hour Showtime
comedy special January 19th Spreckels
those shows are almost sold out there's
less than 200 tickets for both shows
combined most tickets I've ever sold
dude I've raising I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on but I love you guys get
your tickets now for my economy special
January 19th
t f-- @k o that it be that's it but
antastic this the final kid we're out
yeah